foreign
[Music]
stars did Toby and Andrew Spider-Man
ever get home in Spider-Man no way home
and is there a scroll running around the
MCU fighting strangers with the face of
Steve Rogers Captain America and how did
the genie even get inside that lamp in
that magic tiger cave in the first place
this is Rogue Theory the show we talk
about the nerdy titles that we love now
with a new format my name is Mt and
growing Rogue with me today is
spider-woman's Mentor herself it's the
amazing Jessica Clemens what's going on
Jess hey I'm doing good I bet you guys
are wondering why I have a blue screen
now and it's because Brandon our
producer said I fiddle with my keyboard
too much the last episode
hey I I don't think it's not I I
understand this is the most uh the heavy
punishment I've ever gotten as an adult
and I completely understand
[Laughter]
a lot
it's okay and now I'm looking for
something to fiddle with right now I'm
gonna grab the leaves that Brandon
grounded you and that you're like you're
like in detention in the blue dungeon
it's okay hey the blue dungeon is where
we all live it's it's a nice place it's
true look Mt and I are happy being
captured it's mine happy and Punishment
we have Stockholm Syndrome baby we live
in here full time and we love it
we have the same diet as the The Lost
Boys from uh Robin Williams uh Peter Pan
uh we just eat from our imagination yeah
I'm just kidding
[Laughter]
cannot forget about spider Gwen's
understudy it's the spectacular Whitney
van leningham what's going on hi hi hi
I'm mad I'm having a time let's do this
yo I heard that um Gwen's back isn't
feeling all that great so I think you
might be up next so um we're gonna get
the suit ready
oh just kidding I can do Emma Stone
eyeballs baby look at this oh oh that's
on point yeah I dig it those are big
eyes 10 out of 10. I'm calling Andrew
Garfield right now he'll get over it
um
hello it's me it's me your dead
girlfriend
I'm sorry about her but
I want to hang out
let's just play pretend just kidding all
right now it is time for our Rogue
Theory query all right gang because
Peter Parker did not know that you could
just use a telephone to call a college
Something Fishy is happening in the
spider side of the Marvel Cinematic
Multiverse first we had Peter spell
bring our favorite Sony villains and
heroes into the MCU only for the return
spill to end up sending Adrian tombs aka
the vulture into a completely different
Universe presumably because he knew
Peter Parker was Spider-Man this now
establishes that Doctor Strange's return
spell did not work as Dr Strange
intended and could potentially run the
risk of those affected by it like Toby
and Andrew Spider-Man to have no way
back home so we don't know if Toby made
it back home to his unhealthy
relationship with Mary Jane or if Andrew
made it back in time to polish the Stacy
family grave so here are my questions
for my wonderful panel of big brained
homies first question is do you think
that Andrew and Toby Spider-Man actually
made it back to their home universes and
two if not were do you think they went I
mean my immediate thought is wherever
Toby went I hope to God it was a
hospital because he was bleeding he was
bleeding a lot like if he got like I
understand like maybe he didn't get sent
back to his universe but like at least I
hope that wherever he ended up there was
like an ER with a surgeon on standby and
a nurse with a very steady hand and a
needle and some painkillers because he
was bleeding a lot he got stabbed
stabbed Mulan stabbed like literally in
the back by the Green Goblins so like
and it's not the first time he's been
stabbed in the back by the Green Goblin
I know it's a [__] move hey you gotta
watch your back if you got Green Goblet
as an enemy tell it to us right that's
[__] moves it really is [__] move okay
so you want to hear how stupid I am and
actually it's actually not stupid oh my
gosh
I typed out all my answers for today's
book Theory oh my God
but mine are on a Word document I don't
have access to a printer like a mongrel
uh the thing is it would be on my normal
computer if I wasn't banished
it would have been out if I didn't have
the Bluetooth I would have to memorize
all the notes I was gonna say and I was
like no these are getting typed out
these are getting printed so I I but I
think it's really funny the way I wrote
it so I'm gonna read how I wrote it
first and then I will explain
um I said like vulture they were sent to
a different branch and the post credits
scene to Across the spider verse will
reveal both spideys are trying to find
their way back home from the Spidey Hub
and across the spider verse so I think
they got shipped back into the Sony
universe and this is Rogue Theory
ultimately probably they just went back
to their other timelines yeah and
they're dealing with being stabbed and
they're dealing with being cool but my
other Theory to it is that they are
gonna be instead of Tom Holland being
the post-credit or being in into this or
across the spider verse we're gonna get
uh Andrew Garfield and Toby Maguire that
are literally stuck in the spider Hub
because they're like I can't figure out
my way to get back to my normal time
they just sent me here with a bunch of
other Spider-Man luckily this one got
healed from being stabbed but also as an
addition the second part a different
part to that is I also wrote they did
get back to their original time but now
that the villains have changed like
their emotions they've changed who they
are if butterfly affected their world
causing a new Branch causing some
pruning so I also think that their
villains going back to their timeline
and not being villains anymore is it
normal and it would be like hmm you made
a butterfly effect and all this other
chaos in all your towns is just ruined
now so they probably made a butterfly
effect just because like
it's like a Rippy
the thing is break the universe by just
sending a couple of guys to therapy but
I'm a good person now and it's like well
Stanley you're not supposed to be yeah
sorry I feel like that theory is
probably a such a fun and actual theory
for not even just like a good a villain
turning good but like women dying in
comics like if they didn't die in the
movies there'd be like a butterfly
effect where they're like well she was
supposed to die and I'm like wait why
what if she just didn't die what if she
what if Gwen never died what if Gwen's
just a hero and it's like well nope she
has to die or else they won't know that
they're doing something good or bad the
boys so yeah I think this is a good
theory a sound Theory uh that would
happen no I think like these two things
are really
especially this Theory with
um Toby and Andrew potentially heading
to that little Hub of where all the
Spider-Man are in across the spider
verse because I feel like we're gonna
see it like a crossover between the two
I feel like Marvel and Sony are going to
work together on
um a spider-verse movie it's gonna be
amazing so I really like that theory a
lot and this idea of the spell basically
changing the fates of like changing the
timelines of all of these um spider
people wow because that's essentially
what it happened changes the fates of
all these people so like maybe the web
of life and Destiny is all messed up now
I feel like that's a that's a big um
possibility there it'd be funny if Jamie
Foxx's Electro was like wait I'm good
now and they're like no you gotta be
packed yeah I was like sorry you have to
be bad killing people he's like I don't
know is the eternals are making me do I
mean like
yeah
celestials are gonna wipe our planets if
I don't kill everybody big TMF made me
do it I swear they're like in that
Universe there's no Tia mother like who
the [__] is a Tiamat what is a team what
the hell is that like they got purple
aliens over there we don't understand
what's going on
um but yeah a little I like these
theories a lot what do you think Whitney
okay so here's what I think because like
I said I think that uh Toby no matter
what had to end up in a hospital and
here's where he landed he landed in the
version of the universe because okay
let's let's take a little time machine
back to whenever the morbius trailer
came out I don't remember uh when that
was I have mentally blocked it out the
date but it was like a long time ago it
was a long time ago I hope you guys know
that I was the person who wrote all the
notes for the morbius trailer breakdowns
which means that I've seen the mortgage
trailer 900 billion million times you're
welcome basically you're very welcome I
want to kill myself but um
uh so here's what I think in that
trailer there was a version of the
trailer where he goes Dr Michael morby
is at your service and as we all know
that line was not actually in the movie
so I think that Toby got sent to the
universe where Michael Morpheus does say
that line and so when he comes to Dr
Michael Murphy is at your service and
then morbius is like trying super hard
not to drink his like blood gushing but
delicious so he fixes him up and then
and then yeah this is like Jared Leto's
kind of a weird guy Toby Maguire is kind
of a weird guy uh and I think that them
together in a world uh is bad and I'm
glad that it's not our world like I'm
not I'm glad that we don't live in a
world where they're best friends in
their Multiverse they be become best
friends and they have really toxic views
towards women and it's great oh my God
I love this idea of morbius and like
just patching up Toby Maguire's wound
because like it just it's a natural
continuation of that there it works out
very well like if that actually happened
Michael morby is helping him out it's
just like it makes a lot of sense and
like it would potentially draw a lot of
like eyes towards the morbius side of
things if Toby Maguire somehow for some
reason decided to decide on for morbius
that would be the kind it would be the
time that would get us more interested
because nobody's not gonna go watch Toby
Maguire Spider-Man that's like the way
to get us to watch morbius because we'd
have to go see more I mean like let's
not give them any ideas but like it is a
good idea to do that I'm just saying if
they want us to see morbius more if they
want more BS that's what they should do
um
I think that Andrew Garfield I I just
want to say he got home safe because
uh I just want him to he's been through
it Andrew Garfield like I think that
maybe he yeah maybe he just like got
really lucky and he got zapped back the
right way uh I I just yeah I I want
Andrew Garfield to be happy and I want
Toby to go to a hospital those are my
only real requirements here so those are
my theories hey I don't think those are
unreachable I think yeah I don't think
that those are unreachable at all I like
these a lot and like going on to this
Andrew Garfield point I would love if
Andrew Garfield made it into the
spider-gwen universe where like he runs
into spider Gwen he's just like oh my
God you're alive here yeah like this is
so nice
he would be so weird he would be so
weird because Gwen would be like first
off I wasn't dating my peter he was my
best friend and secondly she's dead in
the air Universe well it is
super hot so maybe her Peter wasn't as
hot as this Peter
because uh how are you gonna have a Gwen
that skateboards and plays the drums but
is not gay but isn't gay yeah I know 100
that'd be I would love it he was also so
weird when he came out of his portal and
he was like MJ threw that bread at him
he was so awkward uh Andrew Garfield's
Peter Parker is just so weird he's so
weird and he should be weird he should
be weird Peter Parker has to be a weirdo
creepo but I was like why are you so why
are you so awkward stop being so weird
he's awkward but also very cool like
he's like of course yeah he's part of it
is definitely the coolest Peter Parker
like he has out of all three of them
yeah probably the three of them he's
like the cool Peter Parker
Toby Maguire is probably the do weebiest
Peter yeah I think he's the one that he
thought he was but I think at the time I
I don't know I felt like Andrew Garfield
was the geekiest one maybe it's because
he's like he's a huge nerd but they made
him really cool
he likes skateboards and [__] like in in
The Amazing Spider-Man so like yeah they
made him if he's bullying the bully in
basketball yeah
she's like down no come on
that's like they made him too cool
cool back from the dead from the dead I
know I like this idea of morbius working
on um of Toby McGuire's body that sounds
weird uh but yes I'm working
on his wound and uh see I'm fixing him
up and then potentially maybe even
getting involved in that whole Sinister
Six scenario I'm also just really
picturing morbius starting a cult and
being like you don't have to have just
one MJ Peter let me show you the way and
then like morbius brings him into like
his Jared Leto cult and Toby Maguire
realizes the error of his one-woman ways
he's like oh you know what I mean Toby
McGuire is on that multiple woman wave
in Spider-Man 3 right he was he had um
Gwen Stacy he was like using her to get
to MJ so like you know he's all sort of
on his way there
um but yeah uh no I love both of these
theories a lot
um I think I'm going to have to give
this to Jessica because I really like
um her idea of like you know splitting
the first of all like the multiple like
changing the fates and the potentially
changing the timeline improving the
timeline just by having
um changed villains from the events of
knowing him I like that's a really smart
idea and of course uh they'll be across
the spider-verse connection
um I really do think that we're going to
see Andrew and Toby like Crossover with
those guys because like it's just super
easy to do it's like a it's a voice
acting job that'll pay a lot of money
and people would be super hyped so like
you know I'd love to see him again I
also just realized with that Theory
comes then after no way home being able
to work as a team because they were only
able to work individually but when they
worked as a team they were like oh we
should we are better as a team so now
that they're in the cross the spider
verse where they do team up Spider-Man
things they're like we're good at
working on a team now yeah we can do it
yeah
step aside insecure Spider-Man who think
you have to go at it alone we've done
this before I mean basically like I
really like this idea I like I really
like the moment when they learned how to
use their Peter tingle together and I
think that that's sort of I know that
sounds so weird
oh my God that's gonna be out of shirt
sometimes uh but no
um I really liked when they they learned
how to use their spider sense together
because like that's I think that's very
important to the overall Across The
spider-verse Narrative of like you know
like remember when um Miles Morales
first met his Peter Parker and they had
that weird moment it's like wait a
minute like you're a spider person like
me I feel like that spider connection
and learning how to work together as
Spider people using your Spider Sense in
unison might be a theme that across the
spider-verse
um uses to like you know face whatever
multiversal enemy they need to face in
unison together as Spider people so uh
yeah I think that there's room for
Andrew and Toby to like use their little
antenna to find their friends in the
anime Universe like oh yeah here you are
I'm using my peter tingle to touch
tingles okay oh God all right here we go
I really hope I really hope that
whatever Universe both of them gets sent
to because he's not Peter Parker in
those universes either uh and nobody
knows uh I think that Tom Holland should
just be himself in those universes which
means that both Toby and Andrew have
seen Tom Holland in Drag
dancing to Brianna's umbrella and I like
to believe that that is the new version
of their old pal that they are forced to
deal with on a on a listen listen Peter
Parker needs a job now all right he has
no Aunt May I think that he's dressing
up in Dragon doing drag shows and um
just dancing like um Rihanna I'm not
gonna lie every single time that video
pops up on my feed I I will watch it a
hundred percent no matter how many times
I've seen it before because he's so good
in it he's so good one thousand percent
into it and I'm just like wow you you
went hard on this one
but I really like all these theories um
so thank you for your amazing brains but
let us see what you guys have to say
about this one because we asked you guys
on Twitter where you thought Andrew and
Toby ended up Cleveland boy 23 says I
think they ended up in the place that
all the Spider-Man were at in the cross
of spider-verse too this is what Jess
said so like great minds think alike
very smart Nick drum buddy 14 says they
were taken to the TVA because Kang
pruned their timelines which is very
interesting I like that that's what I
said oh yeah that's kind of the same
thing too Angelica Trey a tray says I'm
still trying to figure out who wore the
butt pad
um which that is a mystery that we
probably need to address here on the
show I don't think either of them did I
think they all have big old booties who
knows who it is it's probably Toby just
kidding
um Marco Gonzalez spider tato 23 says
maybe they swapped universes I think
that'd be really fun to see Andrew and
Toby's universe and Toby And Andrew's
Universe 80 the Creator says uh maybe
alternate versions of their homes like
where some of their historical events
were changed or deaths didn't happen
um which is you know basically sort of
what Jess said like you know they
changed their Fates there
um so I think that'd be really fun but
yeah these are all great theories
everyone's super smart I love all your
theories but up next we respond to one
of your theories that you sent us using
the hashtag root theory in theory Court
but like always be sure to check out
nerdwide.shop where you can always grab
the latest and greatest in new rockstars
gear right now you can grab something
from our this is the way collection
inspired by season three of the
Mandalorian an amazing season go watch
that season it's so good or just let the
world know that you're ready for a seat
at the high table with something from
our John Wick inspired collection John
Wick is very cool and it's it's if you
like dogs go buy this shirt support our
growing network of content here in New
rockstars and grab some merch over at
nerd riotop shop today all right ladies
now it is time for Theory course because
now
I have to uh represent my client
um I had one of my clients came to my
office the other day and he said Mt I
have several thousand dollars in a
theory that I need you to represent I
was like listen sir
um you may lose this several thousand
dollars
I'm telling you right now you'll be my
second case
several thousand dollars that's the
first but I will take this money I'm
taking the money but I will lose now I
assure you I will not I'm saying no
takes these galaxies right now sir and
while I take this money
um but yes that okay now it's time for
me to put my Laura pants on because I'll
be representing and defending my client
and the wonderful Theory here and my
client is needak or
I don't know you're already losing I'm
already losing for your clients I know
I've already taken the money
I don't need to pronounce the name on
the check okay
um and he says or they say
um new Theory the Captain America the
Red Guardian met was a scroll Alexi was
bragging to his cellmates that he knew
Captain America and that they fought in
the 1980s Captain America has been
frozen since 1945 some think he may have
fought Isaiah Bradley I don't think that
really makes any sense he seemed like he
really knew him because he asked Black
Widow if cap talked about him which
shows that he thinks that he did and it
wasn't just a story to make other jail
members scared of him
um so yeah I think that this is a really
good theory I think that like there's a
huge possibility here that
um there was a scroll fight between Red
Guardian and
um a scroll I think like because we know
from Captain Marvel that the Scrolls
went to Earth and they knew of Earth and
like they were just walking around Earth
so there's a potential chance here that
um one of those squirrels that dropped
in Captain Marvel potentially uh fought
him
um fought this this man and pretending
to be Steve and because he saw Steve on
like a piece of memorabilia or like like
what the internet wasn't around there
um but they went to the Steve Museum
they're like oh this is so good I want
to be Captain America too so they
changed their bodies into Captain
America
um so yeah I think this would be really
fun
um what do you guys think okay I'm
taking the pro this week so okay yeah so
I agree absolutely that the Red Guardian
fought a scroll version of Captain
America that's what I'm saying my client
would not like America too they gave me
money okay he has no reason to believe
he didn't fight the real Captain America
and here is why okay how do you
train the guy who you want to become the
Soviet version of Captain America you
train him by making him fight Captain
America and as our Captain America was
clearly Frozen he was a little chilly
chilly cold he could not come to the
phone right now so they gotta scroll and
sorry oh my gosh
how do they get these Scrolls why do
they have these Scrolls why are they
turning these Scrolls into Captain
America just to fight this guy let me
remind you about a little show
Indie show very low key low budget you
may not have ever heard of it but it's
called stranger things baby oh yeah we
know that those people in the 80s they
were capturing demogorgons and using
demogorgons to basically like fight
their like toughest men and then the
toughest men would get eaten and they
were doing experiments like this and
they were trying to find someone who
could like be strong enough to defeat
them but they knew that nobody would
ever be strong enough to defeat them so
they were basically just feeding them
dinner so I think that the mcu's version
of that stranger things scenario is that
these people who ultimately trained him
to become the Russian version of Captain
America they also were experimenting on
Scrolls before they gave him the serum
and and so they experimented on the
Scrolls to make sure that it was like
safe for humans so they made the scroll
Captain America first just to test
things out and then they trained the
Russian Captain America AKA Red Guardian
by having him fight the scroll Captain
America believing it to be the real
Captain America so that there would be
real Stakes
that's what I think
I like this not just because my client
um presented the this Theory and I have
to represent my client but also uh let
us uh Point our attention to a special
uh doggy that I love the most Cosmo the
space dog all right the Russians were
interested in space they had their eyes
out into the cosmos right and I believe
that during their space curiosity they
may have run across a scroll that they
used to train Red Guardian for fighting
people I think that Whitney has a really
great Theory here I think that's a I
think it's a really good representation
um but uh I think they're just probably
had something to say here
um
well yeah he is
for citizens
and I refuse to come to this court today
ready all right State your business
State your case my name is Jessica
Clemens I'm gonna stop this accident
from my my actual Southern family
watches and goes she made it fun of us
okay
sound theories all around I want to
thank you for your your theory who sent
it in but you're a liar and you're wrong
and let me tell you why you lie
I'm gonna start with some senseless
senseless nonsense all the way to facts
right number one during the Cold War the
Soviet Army right Soviet Army recreated
the super soldier serum and gave it and
gave it to the Red Guardian right now
it's up to you guys who you who you
wrote him for the Russians or the
Americans but would it be a better serum
or would it be a diet downed version of
what our Captain America is using right
which one would it be who do I have the
actual super soldier so it's just like
super soldier Serum with aspartame
instead it's actually super soldier
serum zero uh get it right super soldier
somehow yeah and tap it's a Tab cola but
it has
we do know we are very much aware that
1983 to 84 he was frozen in ice and Red
Guardian said it was in 83 and 84. so it
was it was during the time he was a nice
and also if this was the Captain America
that he thinks it is why would a double
down Captain America be running a
rampage playing vigilante against the
Red Guardian who was stealing launch
codes and not get caught
I think the red guardian's an idiot but
I don't think he's that much of an idiot
to think that he's going up against what
is not the real Captain America so I
think this is all a lie coming out of
the red guardian's mouth because if
Shield knew that there was a scroll
pretending to be Captain America they
would have shut that down immediately
because we do know that Nick Fury and
the scrolls are very close so I think
the Scrolls the good ones would have
told him hey this Russians stole one of
our kind and is forcing them to parade
as Captain America and fight the Red
Guardian but what I do like about your
theory is that the Red Guardian could go
up against a scroll the Red Guardian
could go up against the scroll right
wrong why would a regular scroll be able
to ever fight the Red Guardian they
would lose but in this story that the
Red Guardian is telling his friends in
prison he beat them it was launch codes
and he beat him he was it was all in
strength that's what he said so I take
you to the the Marvel numbers
right now
if I had a computer if I had a computer
I would just save the numbers out loud
but Brandon forced me in the blue
dungeon so I had to print them out I
don't put them out there's no computer
over here
just a teleprompter so as you can see
between the Red Guardian and Captain
America Captain America wins in strength
and durability while the Red Guardian
doesn't so is that a diet down version
of the super soldier serum I would say
so and there are War Scrolls and super
Scrolls and if it is a war squirrel a
war squirrel can get the exact same
abilities as Captain America so that
means he would take on these exact
numbers and still beat the Red Guardian
but Jessica what if it's just a Super
Squirrel what it is the Super Squirrel
the Super Squirrel is much stronger than
even Captain America I had to look at
that
oh
we do things out
oh my God the Super Squirrel could beat
Captain America and the Red Guardian so
if this was a scroll it would have won
and instead in this story The Red
Guardian said he won so at the end of
the day it's all still perjury and Lies
by the Red Guardian and was not true
therefore it never existed it is a fairy
tale and it is fallacies and it is fake
lies and I don't stand for it in the
state of Georgia and Alabama Indiana
wherever they actually have this accent
it doesn't work it doesn't stand even
though I am defending my client I've
gotta I have to say Jessica makes some
fantastic points I have to say that it
is truly dedicated
I didn't think about it that people are
probably just listening and not really
watching but secondly I wouldn't have
had to do this if I wasn't banished to
the blue dungeon
my computer just for all the listeners
at home Jessica has printed off multiple
pages to support her argument and has
been holding them up to us so that's
what's happening right now if you're at
home and you can't figure out what the
heck what in the hey what in the hey
we're laughing about that's it you gotta
go to the video don't forget to
subscribe and like while you're happy
when you go watch it like I really like
that you brought up the facts because
like it's so true like it's Captain
America would have beaten
um Red Guardian in a fight if they
actually fought so if it was a scroll
it's probably a dude with the strength
of a scroll and does have the strength
of Captain America at all so yeah I
think that this is very sound I can't
even front
um but I have to defend my my client
here and I have to say that this was
actually a scroll and uh Mike um Red
Guardian wouldn't lie um about fighting
Captain America
um I think that he was telling that
she's a very truthful man
usually people in prison
um were framed and we're usually telling
the truth
um so just kidding uh but yeah I know I
think that uh there's a possibility here
who knows but what do you guys think let
us know in the comment section down
below if you guys be the judge um
because we we like hearing from you guys
because uh you guys got some good brains
now before we leave I want you guys to
give me your 30 second theory but not on
a Marvel thing this time I'm gonna do a
Disney thing this time are you guys
ready for a Disney movie do you guys
know what that um small film called
Aladdin
um it was a very small cartoon no one
really watched it it was from the 90s
Robin Williams really great movie I
don't want to interrupt you I don't want
to interrupt GMT but this is the second
time both of you I don't
small budget picture is
have been Aladdin
ance
yeah those are small projects
Indy no one's ever heard it
seen it no more Classics absolutely
basically uh but no GD from Aladdin
everyone knows him at Aladdin's bestie
who lived in a lamp but very few people
dare to even theorize how Genie even got
inside that freaking lamp until now so
ladies give me your 30 second theory on
how Genie got stuck in the lamp in the
first place I think he was uh this is a
I didn't I didn't know this Rogue Theory
period before this I am going out
absolutely nothing I didn't print
anything out for this is what I'm trying
to say also so I forgot that this was
the Rogue question I know that you told
us yesterday but I come it's okay for
God so I've also
I think Genie was originally a spirit I
think Genie was originally a spirit that
was very into a lot of
okay so maybe he lived in hell all right
he's a spirit he's in Hell he's very
into Kink and domination situations uh
and he messed around with the wrong
Dominatrix and I think this one put
those brass metal bands on him and was
like you know what the safe word is he
never used the safe word and the
ultimate punishment was being locked in
this cage imagine like no don't imagine
don't imagine there's kids that watch
this but you get locked in this cage
that's a lamp for the rest of Eternity
which is the ultimate punishment from a
submissive so I think that's what
happened and it was all an accident on
his end he's probably like got tired of
it after a while he was like damn I
didn't think about eternity how long
eternity wow I was honestly gonna say
the first thing that came into my head
was tried to put his dick in the lamp
and he got stuck and then he had to live
there forever
this is what you get when we both forget
what the question was we don't actually
think
this is great I like this because I like
these legit a 30-second Theory anything
small tempted you're tempted and then
you fully just get sucked in you're like
oh yeah you get sucked in like you're
like
the 10 you just get like oh
vacuum cleaner of all time it's the
worst vacuum the moral of the story is
don't try to put your dick in things and
always say yourself yeah the moral of
the story is fleshlights feel a lot
better probably than a lamp
um oh my god
oh but no these theories are great even
though they were they were just like
really crazy and off the cuff I love it
so much
um I'm gonna have to give this one to um
I'm gonna give it to Whitney because I
like this it's magic it's Temptation you
know they're both these are both very
sexual theories but like the Temptation
the Temptation is a real one the
Temptations are real and you're like
well I could just a little just a tip
Genie doesn't have a lower half uh for a
reason so maybe they got stuck and uh
they got uh goofed off see that's why
it's like a little wispy ghost external
punishment it'd be like internal
punishment
sad sad times that's why he uses comedy
to get over it
um but anyway that is it for this crazy
episode of Rogue Theory thanks to our
amazing guest Whitney van lening him and
Jessica Clemens if you have your own
Rogue theory for any of our topics today
be sure to drop them in the comments
below or use the hashtag Rogue theory on
Twitter
um you support our Channel by checking
out all of our awesome merch over at
nerdrive.shop follow me at masertainment
following rockstars on all social
platforms and be sure to subscribe to
our channel here on YouTube see you guys
next time we love you guys so much thank
you for spending time with us bye
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]